my day job in general as I work on the
Apache Iowa libraries directly I
primarily work on the native
implementations the C plus and go
implementations uh but you know Voltron
itself a lot of the committers on the
Apache Hour project do work at Voltron
data and right now the current public
product of Voltron is uh Enterprise
support for Apache Arrow
um and just kind of improving the
ecosystem and building those connections
and bringing things together and as he
said I wrote the book on Arrow literally
because there's just the one really oh
anyways uh but yeah so without further
Ado it is well it's hard to talk about
our Arrow database connectivity if you
aren't necessarily familiar with what
arrow is so that's what we're going to
do first just a very quick primer on
Apache Arrow you've probably heard it
you've probably heard it mentioned
people probably talked about it but you
may not actually know what it is or you
might know what it is and then great I
like that but in the meantime
um so patchy arrow is a in-memory format
specifically a column oriented in-memory
format that is highly performant for
analytics and analytical workflows
the format in memory is identical no
matter which implementation you're using
whether using C plus go rust Java
doesn't matter the in-memory layout is
identical
which means that you can take the bytes
the raw bytes you have and pass them
across the wire you can pass them in
between processes you can pass them
around as is without having to see
realize or deserialize you know as Tina
was just saying about duck deep about
the bigquery talk about where they have
a huge cost in having to serialize and
then deserialize data that they passed
from one node to the other with bigquery
Arrow gets around that now if Network
latency becomes a problem yes the in yes
the inter-process communication format
does allow for compression if that is
your bottleneck
but in most cases your theoretical Max
limit is just Network bandwidth or your
memory bandwidth or whatever you can do
um and the other big feature of Arrow is
that it's polyglot there's
implementations in so many
languages like I didn't list them all
here that's there's more than what's
listed there and that's kind of the big
idea there is that whether you're
writing
a client or a server or you're writing
anything that can interact with
something else Arrow becomes a glue that
you can create interoperability with
while still maintaining that performance
and that communication and that comes
from being column oriented columnar
if you aren't familiar with the term if
you're not used if you haven't heard it
before column oriented kind of goes like
this if you saw Julian's talk about the
history of like parquet and open lineage
earlier today you saw a similar uh it
was a similar graphic that he had where
the way you lay out the data in memory
for a row oriented layout you typically
see it kind of like the one on the right
there it's kind of like that you know
array of structs where the data is in
memory is split up based on you have
struct one row two Row three so on so
forth whereas column oriented you're
going to group the data for individual
columns together in memory
why does that matter
well when you're performing analytical
workflows or any kind of interactions
and decisions there there's a lot of
benefits you can get by having that data
grouped together
so using the example I just gave you you
know with the with the archers and the
locations and I hope you got some of the
jokes that were on there
um
if you wanted to grab all the archers in
Europe from that little tiny table
well in the row oriented area you'd have
to read
you know the whole chunk for every row
and then you could jump around in memory
going from Royal row
to check which ones you wanted that were
actually from Europe
and then get their names from jumping
around in memory
and that can be cost that can cost them
that's that's not cost effective
um you might be able to get away with
reading a subset but
CPUs use cash use cash levels and the
cash layers have certain sizes so you
end up just reading the whole chunks of
data anyways
in the column oriented scenario
you're able to just
read one chunk of memory
is the value for the location column
and then you get the indexes you need
and then you read one chunk of memory
for the names
and now you can just go indexed index in
the columns and there you go you got
your data and now you've reduced your i
o
you didn't have to read anything about
the years
so you have less i o cost it's one of
the it's one of the reasons why parquet
is so efficient because you get that
column oriented on disk so you if you
only need to read one column you don't
need to read the whole file you just
read the chunks for that column
same idea but in memory for how you
access the memory
the other at the other advantageous
piece of it is that vectorization of
computation you may have heard of like
Cindy's single instruction multiple data
where you have the processor runs one
instruction and perform an operation on
multiple values at one time
vectorization
one of the requirements to do that is
that your data has to be contiguous in
memory
you you can't take
uh integer here here here and here and
run a vector operate operation on that
you have to copy them all over into a
single chunk of memory
then run your vectorized information but
if you have a column oriented memory
buffer
everything's already in that vectorized
contiguous chunk and you can easily run
those vectorized operations on them
so that's kind of the pull here that's
why you want the column oriented data in
your in memory when you're doing things
so
this but this talk is titled Arrow
database connectivity
and how do most people interact with
databases
well they use odbc and jdbc
so
let's start there
and kind of go over okay in your
standard workflow you're building an
application you want to talk to a
database
the standard way is going to look
it's kind of something like this
you're going your application is going
to submit a query
that query is going to go to the odbc
jdbc API
that's going to get sent to whatever
driver it's using
which will then send it off using some
database specific Network protocol
database operates does its query
executes does its thing
it's going to return
that data in the database specific
format
it's going to go back across using that
database specific wire
and then your driver is going to
translate that result set into the
format that OBC and jdbc require which
is typically a row oriented format
and that's kind of your standard
workflow nowadays now some people can
get around that if you have a good drive
good enough driver the driver can
improve that communication but that's
really that's generally how it works
so
jdbc and OBC exists for a reason
you know when they were created back in
the 80s it was the idea of being making
it so that making it easier on
application developers so you only had
to write against the single API
but you could access tons of other
databases and just swap out drivers
which is a good thing
except that data then and data now and
computers have changed a lot and odbc
and JBC are row oriented because at that
time in the 80s your data sets were
primarily
tons of rows
fewer columns
that's just the typical way things were
operated
and you when you use and but and you
also weren't dealing with the enormous
amount of data that we do now
so when you want that column oriented
interaction
odbc and jdbc are not good for that
because now you have to transpose that
data
at both sides
so
but LGBT and JPC aren't going anywhere
they're ubiquitous everyone uses them
they are the generic connector that you
know if you were making anything you
utilize lgbc jdbc or you know it's table
Stakes if you if you can't use lgbc and
jdbc then you're dead in the water
so they're not going anywhere we're not
gonna we're not going to kill them we're
not going to get rid of them
as much as we want to
so when you have that
column oriented database dremio click
house Google bigquery even duck DB
when you start wanting to get those
improvements and get past that cost of
the trans of the transposition from
columns to rows you start looking into
date into libraries that do that
you know turbo DBC Arrow jdbc various
libraries that try to do that conversion
for you or improve just to reduce those
costs
and then when that's not fast enough you
go to the actual database specific sdks
but once you go to the database specific
SDK now you've defeated the purpose of
using odbc and jdbc because now you're
gonna have to write an adapter for every
single database you want to communicate
with so that you can use their
individual SDK
and then because you want things to be
faster that's what it's all about it's
performance
and that's where this thought comes in
that is
that's your starting point that's what
you have now
and I'm telling you there's a better way
and that's Arrow database connectivity
thank you uh okay I'm done right ready
okay no adbc so
um
adbc is that single client API
but the interface it exposes is Apache
Arrow oriented and the arrow native
it's not we're not intending to
we're not we're not going to replace
odbc and jdbc in the generic sense
you know but if you're doing a bulk
column oriented columnar computations
analytical workflows
this is what you want to use and you're
going to get benefits
tons of benefits from it and it's
available in lots of languages already
including if you really like that go
Arrow the Go Gopher and the uh the snake
icons see me in my little office hours I
have giant stacks of stickers of them
so please you want stickers come get
them they're adorable and I love them my
Graphics team loves me like it's fun
when you can go to the graphics team and
they're like I need
I need an image of a gopher with a bow
and arrow
or I need an image of a snake being
launched from a bow
so it'll shout out to Voltron data
graphic graphic design guys you guys
nailed it
okay so let's look at that that example
again the the workflow we showed earlier
let's look at that again
but this time we're going to do it using
adbc
so you've got your application you got
your query you're going to send your
query to the API to the you know adbc
adbc is a spec
and then you hit whatever driver you're
using whether using Arrow flight SQL or
maybe you're using a postgres because
you're going to a row oriented database
um the driver is going to translate the
query however it needs to do it and then
send that query in whatever database
specific format it needs
and you're going to and ideally the
database is going to execute and return
arrow data that's the ideal scenario
but like if you're going to postgres
you're not getting Arrow data back
unfortunately at least not yet maybe
they will who knows
um
so when you get the data back
if it is needed if it's necessary
the driver can then translate transpose
shift the data into Arrow from whatever
that Source was
if you have the ideal scenario where
you're getting Arrow data back from your
database like if you're using dremio or
your or big bigquery or anything else
that can return arrow data
then it just passes it through
no translation no transposing ideally no
copying it just takes the bytes as they
come off the wire
and hands the pointer to that those
bytes to your to what you need
and then you get your application just
iterates over batches of Apache Arrow
data regardless of where the data came
from
but so in this case you can use adbc and
use Arrow
interactions and get data from postgres
and then change your driver out and go
to dremio
at its core adbc is just an interface
defined in a c header
anything that can do extern c
and expose that interface
can be used by the implementations for
AWC that's the course the basic of it
and the reason for that is because Arrow
has a c data interface that's defined a
couple small structures that are a
little bit of metadata and then some
pointers to the buffers so that you can
pass data across a c boundary without
copying it
so your driver can take the data it got
back as is from the database and just
handed off
to the application without the cost of
making copies of those buffers of data
and that works no matter what language
you're in because almost every
programming language has some way to
talk via a c boundary because that's
just the ubiquitousness of the way it is
now
the API and the driver is still under
development
um we we just released version 0.3.0
and that included a sqlite postgres and
arrow flight SQL drivers
but it did also have implementations in
CEC plus Java go python Ruby someone's
building a rust implementation also
there's an R implementation being worked
on
so on and so forth and if you guys have
ideas of or want to help contribute
please do
um but the idea is that in the header
file uses free functions and typedefs
and enums to maintain as much as
possible that ABI compatibility across
releases so that things don't break out
from under you
so as long as you can meet the interface
you work
so when we're talking about like where
does this fit
you know we're looking at okay so now we
have you know the old xkdc X you know
skcd comic you know we had 14 standards
let's make a one to fix it all now we
have 15 standards where is adbc fit
so you've got your
row oriented
Technologies jdbc oubc odbc does have a
column oriented thing but it the type
system isn't Rich enough to really work
with arrow and people just don't tend to
really use it
um and then you have your protocols
your apis and protocols
and ABC is that aeronative
vendor neutral
API
that's where it fits in this whole thing
like I said before
We're not gonna kill JBC or odbc like
even as much as we want to this isn't
going to kill it but
this is going to give a way forward for
doing high performance bulk columnar
analytical workflows to get your data
because it ends up being extremely fast
now of course you might say but wait
I've heard about Arrow flight now see a
flight SQL
why do I buy what why is there adbc if I
have Arrow flight or flight SQL or what
why
they complement each other
it's not a replacement it's not you know
ABC does not replace flight SQL it's a
complement to it
to to oversimplify
um
when you're dealing with a database
system you typically have three pieces
three components you've got a client
you've got a server you've got a
transport protocol
yes it's oversimplified but just stay
with me here
um
on the client side you get a big benefit
by having a single API you can code
against for your application that no
matter what database you're trying to
hit you don't have to change your code
just change your connection string
that's very advantageous
your wire protocol
could be different based upon what
database you're going and by having that
something like adbc on the client side
you don't have to care as an application
developer
on the server side if you're a database
developer if your database vendor
you get a really cool advantage of if
you build say an arrow flight SQL
interface for your database
you get to reach everybody
and not have to build your own driver
you just expose a flight SQL interface
and anyone can use your data because in
addition to adbc's fights equal driver
there's also dremio released last year a
ogbc jdbc driver
that works with aeroflight SQL
so Arrow flight SQL becomes a standard
for the server side that you just get a
ton of stuff for free and can reach all
your clients if you're a database
developer by having that as your server
interface
but
if you're not using that you can still
just build an adbc driver maybe you
think there's a you have a better way of
communication or transport
and you can still make it easy to get
that column oriented interface and not
have to pay cost of transposing your
data
from that column to row
and then often when you're trying to do
analytical workflow you want the data in
column oriented anyways so now you want
from column to row and then on the
client side you went back from row to
column now you're doing all these
Transmissions or you can just use adbc
and that's kind of where we are now yes
some people might not yet be able to
switch to AWC because we don't have all
of the drivers yet
they're being worked on when we can but
please look it up contribute it's all
open source just like just like Arrow
it's part of the Apache era project
so please contribute and come help
um I'm going to be working on a
snowflake adbc driver soon
but
you know there's still needs like
clickhouse bigquery whatever else
there's still features that aren't fully
there for the postgres one
now
the fun part
actually showing you code examples of
this whole thing in action
because well what good is it if you
don't know how to use it
so let's look at the python the python
package first
you can actually just install dip
install adbc driver sqlite or adbc
driver postgres ADB site ABC driver
flight SQL
they're all python packages that you can
install via pip you can also get them
via conda
or Mamba whoever you prefers
and the python API for AWC implements DB
API 2.0 so any of your existing code
that already relies on Python's DB API
interface
can work directly with adbc off the bat
but it also adds this fetch Arrow table
method that if you have Pi Arrow
available
you can call fetch Arrow table and
you'll just hand you the arrow table
data
without having to convert without
copying
you know all the benefits I just talked
about
and you can see here like all you have
to do is if you change you know
which thing you imported
and your connection string
the rest of the code can stay the same
which is the reason why you use odbc or
jdbc in the first place only now we're
going to get
column oriented
now this is a higher this is the high
level API there's also a lower level API
we expose at the lower level a driver
manager
remember I said that adbc as core is
you know a c header file that defines an
interface
that means that any shared allegory and
you share the object that exposes that
extern c interface can be loaded
and then delegate to it
so you can dynamically load drivers
by just telling it you know the path to
the to the shared object
and it loads it up and then you can use
it as long as it meets the interface so
it has and exposes the functions that it
can call
and then that lets you do a couple
things you can use multiple drivers
simultaneously
you know you can create one instance
that loads one library and another
instance that loads another library and
there you go
um you can decouple
your data from dip from specific drivers
instead of having import adbc driver
sqlite you can just import ABC driver
manager and then parameterize
the driver and the connection string
and now you've further decoupled
everything and made it more modular more
modular more modular and easier to use
easier to make it more ubiquitous and it
makes the drivers reusable
this one I like a lot because I do a lot
of work in go and the arrow flight SQL
driver for that is distributed with that
python module
is a shared Library distribute with the
wheel that was written in go
and then compile to a shared object
and the reason is because you get a
single
shared object that we can load with
almost no dependencies
if I do this traditional C plus way I'd
have to either make a build system to
statically link in everything I needed
or I have to distribute flight SQL lib
Arrow grpc
flight you know all these things or
I can build it and go
and then distribute one shared object
not only that but it means I also don't
need to re don't need I can reuse the
code because we need a native go
implementation anyways
so all I do is take the native go
implementation wrap it with seago extra
and C calls
and now I can use it whether you're
coming from C plus because you can just
link against it extern C or python Ruby
R any of those things that you need to
link against that you know you're not
implementing this natively in can use it
and you have almost no dependencies to
it and it works in multiple environments
I can build it for Windows I can build
it from Mac I can build it for arm
I can build it for s390x IBM Mainframe
yes I have done this
and it's reusable in all those
situations
so let's look at the Go Side
for the go interface it just literally
implements it just describes the
interface notice the difference here is
that you know the difference being here
like in the python implementation you
have the DB API
it used pythons
standardized interface and made it
available to utilize AWC while still
also giving you the benefits we do the
same thing on the Go Side you've got a
native go driver but it's also got a
driver manager
because go can use cigo which means I
can load
any
adbc driver that say with me exposes the
C interface
you expose those functions and the go
can use it
you know and there you go it's
completely reusable you write it in C
plus and I can load you here if I need
to
um and then we also provide a wrapper
you can wrap around it so that you can
use it in the context of goes
standard database interface
and then suddenly you get access to
anything that has an adbc driver
with the standard database SQL interface
or you can just use the adbc interfaces
and get the arrow data directly
it's it's not difficult to understand it
because we use similar Concepts the
concepts are fairly equivalent when
you're thinking about what we're talking
about the adbc versus other things
whether you're dealing with
a connection
the query State prepared statements
result sets you know it they may be
called different things in different
apis and different interfaces but
they're basically equivalent in
conceptual idea
so it's not hard to wrap your head
around
and we don't we don't stop at just being
able to execute the query and get
results
you can do bulk ingestion
without with adbc if you have any
something else that provides you a
stream of record batches
you can send those to insert them into a
table
if the driver supports it you can send
them to create a new table from this
list of record batches if the driver
implements it
if you have a partitioned result set
so one example with arrow flight Arrow
flight SQL is when you make a request
with a query
it can return to you a list of locations
and you consume all the locations which
you can do in parallel to get the whole
data set
if your data if your server side can
support partitioning out like that
adbc also supports that as an interface
so if your database does have that way
of saying
here's a bunch of partitions that you
can get in parallel
ABC driver can take advantage of that
and use it and you can get the benefits
of that parallelization
it also has transaction Primitives
you know you know we we tried to get as
much of that
primitive uh based
SQL workflow that we could into the
interface
but if you look at it and there's a
piece that's not you can't do with the
interface
file an issue on the repo please we want
this to be usable and ubiquitous in
every scenario we can
so if you want more information
uh you got you know the arrow
arobachi.org adbc website has all that
has documentation information links to
the repo and other things about how you
install how you install it download it
and stuff like that you can get it there
if you want more information on Apache
arrow in general maybe you've only heard
it and haven't played around with that
much with it
we have the Apache Arrow doc Docs
or you can get my book
you know the book is a whole thing on
Arrow but not just to explaining the
arrow format and you know how do you use
it but also in context you know examples
of how you make spark faster using Arrow
of how you can leverage arrow in
different workflows
and benefit from it
um and the examples in the book are
provided in Python C plus plus and go
and there's a GitHub repo that has them
all there
um yes this is definitely my Shameless
plug thank you
um but the idea being get more
information as you need if you need it
find me talk to me email me you know I'm
Matt Voltron data.com
and yeah that's the
that's what I got
foreign